la taupe c'est très bien nagé elle peut
mettre même mettre la tête plusieurs
minutes sous l'eau jérôme et au pied
comme le fut son père sa mission réguler
les populations de taupe ce petit
mammifère de quelques centimètres de
long fait en effet le malheur des
jardiniers comme ici dans le parc du
château de versailles
donc là vous voyez là la taupe a attaqué
à la creuse est pratiquement trentaine
de mètres là dans la nuit on est devant
le petit trianon
donc on peut pas laisser une pelouse
comme ça saccagé le petit trianon et
cette demeure coquette où
marie-antoinette émettant se replier
aujourd'hui pour conserver l'harmonie du
paysage qui lui fait face
jérôme posent tous les quinze jours des
pièges à toute la troupe de galeries il
ya toujours deux galeries l arrivée ici
elle a poussé la terre et elle continue
donc là je vais mettre deux pièges il se
sert de cet outil en acier cuivré appelé
piège putanges une méthode mécanique et
écologique qu utilisaient déjà andré le
nôtre le jardinier de louis xiv
jérôme l'a relancé il ya une dizaine
d'années et voici le résultat
et voilà là on a une petite femelle elle
a bien été prise juste derrière la tête
donc là pas sûr faire c'est parfait
découvrons l'animal à l'état vivant par
chance jérôme a réussi à en capturer une
le matin du tournage c'est parti pour
une séance d'exercices ballon on va voir
je vais vous montrer à la toque manche
pour 90% de vers de terre
donc elle est capable de manger
pratiquement son poids par jour en vers
de terre elle est capable de s'enterrer
en quelques secondes en la finaux de
préfère s'enfuir sous la terre l'épreuve
de natation s'avère plus réussies
content 5000 à 10000 individus la
population de taupe du parc de
versailles croît grâce au recul des
produits chimiques
seuls 300 d'entre elles sont supprimés
chaque année